foreign
[Music]
Labs at Purdue University under the
direction of Professor Graham Cooks and
today I want to talk to you a little bit
about this novel high throughput
technology that we've been developing
for the past six or seven years which is
based on the absorption electrospray
ionization mass spectrometry for decims
which we think has a lot of applications
particularly for reaction screening
nanoscale synthesis and by analysis
so to start really talking about
what this platform can do and how it
works I think first we need to
set some Concepts straight and the first
one is okay we're saying that this
platform is based on Desi description so
what is that well that is an ambient
ionization method now we get what that
means in a minute but it basically works
by using a charge solvent display that
impacts on the surface and then your
sample is deposited on this surface or
your surface is your sample
then there's a micro extraction event
occurring and splash micro droplets as
you're seeing the GIF on the bottom left
of the video are splashed and those are
the micro droplets that carry the
reserve analytes to the mass
spectrometer
so that involve this micro extraction
event I involve this secondary micro
droplets and those are two quite
important uh
points for later in in this talk
so I mentioned that that's it was an
ambient ionization method what what they
hope does this mean well this means that
um you can perform analysis of samples
directly in the open air without or with
very minimal sample preparation you
don't have to do this ionization in
vacuum and you retain of course all the
capabilities of Ms without having to
have your ionization happening through
for example lines of solvent going
around or happening in Solo vacuum
chamber using a lace for example
and that it was the first of
such methods and currently you can find
many many of them including paper spray
or Dart which was created about the same
time like that
and of course many more are article
so if you have heard anything about
Daffy and if you have not that's okay
but since it's exception and if you've
heard about it you've probably known
Desi because of tissue Imaging or
Imaging chemical Imaging in general
so
it seems as he started here you see some
reference 2008 or something
Desi has been used to image
samples in particular tissue section but
also others like fingerprints like you
here see in this example where you don't
only keep the distribution the profile
of the fingerprint but you can also get
chemical composition for example here I
think it was a person that touched
cocaine and you can see uh cocaine from
the fingerprint
but the question now is how do you take
this Imaging capabilities which is what
this is mostly known for and translated
to high throughput
kind of workflow and and the answer is
in fact simple if you think about a
tissue section or a fingerprint in its
most
abstract way you will think about just
chemicals uh different mixtures of
chemicals with different compositions
that then your
having certain special distribution
across the tissue across the fingerprint
so make sure those compounds with
certain special distribution you can
make that two in the lab if you make
your own
array of mixture of compounds with a
special distribution that you define you
can apply in the same principles of
doing Imaging to perform High throughput
analysis and that's how you obtain some
of these figures here on the bottom
right of the corner
word your Imaging a generated array of
reaction mixtures and you're getting for
example where you generate your products
of these reactions and you can apply
this not only to reaction make sure but
you can create an array with vinyl
fluids you can create an array with
biological assay samples and so on and
so forth
but to actually convert the Imaging idea
to the high throughput experiment you
have to take into account some other
couple of factors
the first one is that the Imaging
experiment
usually involves rastering because if
you want to acquire a higher resolution
image of sample it's a tissue section
you're going to have to raster across
the tissue section making lines and then
making those lines close to each other
because your resolution will depend up
how fast you're going across each line
and how close you can put those two
lines together
closer you can put them this will evolve
high resolution they're all great
but for the hydropod experiment you
actually don't care about the resolution
you care about going fast usually those
two go in opposite directions if you
look at the picture shown on the screen
right now you will see that if you do
the raster and experiment on that array
of on an array of samples you're being
very inefficient you're spending a lot
of time over white space basically over
space that has no sample and you're
resting the same sample several times so
you're getting redundant information
besides if not you imagine that you
don't put all these samples but just put
half of them well you're going to take
the exact same amount of time which is
also not very efficient not very logical
so this is not a good way of doing it
it's not the best way of doing so what
do we do well we can take now the
positions of this array that we created
because we created so we know that the
positions are fixed within the array we
just need to calibrate the corners of
the array with that you can create a
virtual grid and you can just move
through any of the positions on the grid
you don't have to go to all of them you
can can select which ones to go and by
calibrating these positions and
selecting to which of the spots you want
to jump you can do something like if
it's showing now on the slide and you
can jump from sample to sample spending
about half of a second per sample that
is a trip that we work currently but
half of a second per sample before
jumping to the next one and this gives
you the flexibility of analyzing
whatever number of samples you want just
a subsection of all the ones that you
put in or all of them and you waste very
minimal space in jumping compared to
rusting and you're actually investing
most of your time trying to do the
analysis and this allows you to achieve
throughputs better than one sample per
second which is the way the rate at
which we currently operate
there's another important factor and
this is mostly applicable to reaction
screening and is that if viewers reading
organic reactions you're typically going
to have to mix your reagents and then
incubate them or
kid them or whatever it is but you have
to waste some time before you actually
read the products of these reaction if
you think about the round bottom flask
reaction you're gonna have to put it on
a hidden block for hours overnight
whatever it is to then see the reaction
the next day to find the products
but that limits a little bit of your
true but right despite you can do this
in batch and so on in them it's a little
bit of future
here we have another factor that is
quite important and is that we can do
the screening of accelerated reactions
and this has to be to a phenomenal that
occurs in those micro droplets that I
refer to at the beginning that generate
fourth from the Desi event
and in those micro droplets because of
the high surface to volume ratio that
surface has very particular property
so if you put for example a reagent in
the Desi spray and another reagent in
the surface or you put both on the
surface it doesn't matter they will get
mixed in these droplets and when you see
at the end you will see the product of
those reactions either they just deposit
here on the surface or if these droplets
are sample from the Mass Spectrum
and
this occurs in in milliseconds disrupts
have millisecond samples so you're
seeing the product of reaction is very
very very fast and this is due to this
particular surface of the droplets in
which you have an interface between the
gas phase and the solution phase
and one of the main hypotheses of why
this acceleration happens is basically
because of the particularity of this
interface so you're kind of on an
in-between State between a solution
phase reaction which you have to
overcome this huge energy barrier as you
see in the green line and the gas phase
reaction which you basically go downhill
and then up on every effective Collision
you get a reaction so you're somewhere
in between where your reactions can get
accelerated by several orders of
magnitude up to probably a million and
there's a distance between the highest
the fastest solution phase and and the
cash phase reactions
and of course their other particular
phenomena and interfaces that become
quite important for example you can have
high electric fields on the interfaces
and generate a reactive species radicals
but also you have extreme PHS which can
protonate things that for example cannot
be protonated or wouldn't be permeated
generally speaking for example CO2 that
can get proclamated and then be
abstracted to for example capture CO2 as
Carbonic acids using just droplets of
containing amines
and if you put all these Concepts
together the idea of this is translating
the Imaging experiment to the how to put
experiment the idea of going to spot to
spot the idea of having accelerated
reactions then you can consolidate the
platform that we have and use today so
on the slide right now you see the
processes and the instrumentation
involved on the high throughput system
its current version so first we have a
fluid handling robot in which we can use
to prepare to automatically prepare the
samples let's say that it's organic
reactions or that is biological assets
whatever it is and we can prepare them
in any format if they need
to be for example incubated enzymatic
reactions or whatever it is but at the
end we want to end up with a 384
wallpaper and in this trailer for
wallpaper we use it because we have a
384 pin tool this pin tool has a 50
nanoliter it's calibrate for 50
nanoliter transfers so we were seeing
just very very small nanolver Ali quotes
to generate high density arrays from the
384 wall plates to what we call a
deciblings this is definitely just a
glass slide coated with a PTFE membrane
which is what you see that white
rectangle with some dots in the middle
of the screen
and in this recipe plate we can spot
using the pinto up to 16 different 384
wall plates or replicates of the same
one making high density arrays with
6144 samples per click or any multiples
of 384 that you want you don't have to
put 6 000 if you don't want
so this arrays with nanometer uh samples
are then transferred automatically from
the robot to the death stage of a mass
spectrometer and we've coupled two
different systems uh to the to the
overall High throughput platform
and in one of them you can see a black
box with some bottles around myself uh
flow switch Matrix which acts as a
solvent deliverer system so you can
change your decision solvent in between
blades or you're going to create
gradients across blades and so on and so
forth or
then once you get to the decision stage
basically the analysis occurs
automatically you move after calibrating
the positions of the spots you just move
across jumping sample to sample spending
less than half of a second in each
sample before jumping to the next one
with overall throughputs better than one
sample per second and in those secondary
droplets of the testing you can have
this accelerated organic reactions as is
noted in the or enter sandal eventually
once you finish your blade you have a
huge amount of spectral data that you
have to process and when the user starts
this whole uh workflow from the fluid
howling workstation it also inputs a
plate layout which basically contains
okay what did you put in what are you
looking for which I'm over Z values are
you interested on each one of the Wells
on each one of the samples
so using that user input and the Roma
spectral data you process everything
together and generate a peak list which
associate the information that the user
requires for each one of the samples and
with that you can generate interactive
heat Maps or any other sort of output
which is more more tailored to whatever
you want to do for example if you're
doing quantitation or if you're doing
some enzyme kinetics which have
automated code
to do all this from the mass spectral
data
now from this let me show you how it
works in real life with this now let me
show you a video of how it happens
so here first we're seeing the deck of
the fluid handling workstation we're
taking the pin tool the pinto dips and a
well plate and then it transfer to the
tassi plate which is that wide thing
it's like last Light coded with a pdfe
membrane then you take the density plate
that is just supported on the 3D printed
holder but it's easier for the robot to
graph it will put in a shuttle and then
it will send it to the back of the robot
where you will take the slide again and
then put it on the Desi stage for the
analysis to start
now we're seeing the screen of the
computer
that is connected to the master monitor
so first step is going to just be
calibrating the positions of all these
samples and this can be done
automatically with image recognition
software but here so manually we go
through the corners we know all the
positions of our rate then we start as
we're seeing now the stage is moving
underneath the spray some of the spots
have some color and you can see them
moving then here you see live Mass
spectral data acquisition all the
spectrums are coming from that
experiment samples we're spending more
or less half a second and we just spot
before jumping to the next one so the
overall throughput is better than one
sample per second
and of course it's dependent on the
density of the spots you have the more
spots you have the less distance you
have to jump so you can go a little
faster overall but we are spending about
half a second we just spot acquiring
tree for Mass Spectrum scan my Spectrum
scans
then here you see on the
right that you generate this interactive
heat map basically in real time with the
data acquisition system if you clicking
of this particular response you will see
the Mass Spectrum and the corresponding
Mass Spectra and then you can filter by
intensities by the type of reaction you
had and so on like we're doing here
right now doing filtering my reach
so this are the key Concepts this is how
the platform works now what have we done
with this lecture what are the
applications well when we finger the
main pillars of of applications of the
system is basically the three key steps
of a drug Discovery workflow you want to
screen reactions to generate molecules
in here let's call them candidates
generate these molecules and then you
want to be able to synthesize these
molecules in amounts enough that you can
test which you can assessor by
activities and then whichever compounds
you find which Stronger by activity then
you just basically regenerate analogues
iterate and buy properties
so we think this platform can
consolidate this whole Discovery
workflow in a single system so let me
try to show you how
so we focus on the first step which is
screening now let's see what we've done
well with the green several organic
reaction types here's the two examples
of results obtained for the Suzuki cross
coupling there are many many many more
that we've explored and they just shows
you the diversity of chemistry that you
can study we can study for example uh
the the reaction mechanisms itself see
what is the influence of the
stoichiometry in the orders of addition
the different ligands solvents catalysts
and so on we can optimize a particular
transformation to find the optimal
synthetic conditions or we can just
assess in general reactivity trends
because I told you about this micro
droplet accelerated phenomenon one of
the main questions that we get is okay
is this this comparable so what you get
with Desi that you say that you can go
really fast going less than one second
per sample and having these reactions in
droplets and so on that this really
compare with what you obtained with the
normal screening an answer is yes so if
you compare the Desi results with lcms
results you will see that the trends are
in general pretty much comparable but
what you get with this is that you save
orders of magnitudes in terms of time
and solvent consumption as you will see
in the bottom of the screen of course
these heat maps are on the same
intensity scale you see that the test
intensity is a little lower but that is
known as it gives you a little lower eye
intensity than lcms but the trends are
pretty much identical
and another question will be okay it
does work but do your reactions is
represent to this super fast platform
really translate to a scale up
conditions for example flow synthesis
the answer is yes two so we're for
example explore the synthesis of what
we've seen and in particular the
nitrogation step that you
know that you actually scheme at the top
of the slide you can explore different
solvents different naturalization agents
and so on and so forth and the optimal
conditions found using dimensive
screening were translating amongst other
to compare to a flow synthesis setup and
surprise the conditions that were found
optimal with the CMS system were also
found optimal for longitude synthesis in
the flow setup providing milligrams per
hour long seen with high yields
again
now we've recently also tried to explore
other types of reactions instead of
taking simple building blocks try to
derivatives already active and complex
molecules because this takes you closer
to the uh kind of drug Discovery works
with your fine active molecules that you
generate analysis and you have to test
them again
so this case we've demonstrated with for
example a setimize which is a medication
used for to treat a high cholesterol
and we've tried to derivatize the
phenolic group of acetamine if using
several reaction security accumulation
or for example this acid-like chemistry
so uh that is the reaction that you're
seeing on the bottom of the screen and
as you see we found this reaction being
very dependent on the solving
composition the Stoichiometry of the
reaction which are the numbers you see
below the heat map and the iso compound
that you're using for the conjugation as
you also can see from the heat map on
the right you see the full Mass Spectrum
of the reaction in which you see that
the main Pixar is still the
non-functionalizes that it must but you
can identify to study a sodium addict of
the isochondic acid like conjugated
molecule that you can also characterize
through tandem mass spectrometry and
that is another of the great
capabilities of the platform that if for
example you have something that you
don't know what it is or you want to
confirm the structure you can just go
back after the whole screen and go back
to that same spot and then acquire msms
data with that same little amount of
sample that you put in and I think I
forgot to mention but the pen tool that
we use is calibrated for 50 nanometers
so we're using 50 nanoliter samples to
perform on the analysis that typically
translate to low nanograms to picograms
or even lower of sample
with very very good results because it
allows you to both do full amounts and
do a mass MS
and then you can also instead of doing a
single transformation you can explore
all different reactions that you want so
this is in a single experiment I think
we explore reactivity Trends across
22 or so reactions on the left you see
some example in aspect of this reaction
so if you see the bottom you will see
mostly what is left is the base the use
for the reaction besides of that is all
products so the reaction seems complete
and on the top you will see that you
still have a lot of reaction left over
that's right to actually mean and you
have two peaks one corresponds to the
product 235 and at 233 that we don't
know what it is so how can we figure it
out well as I told you we can do msms to
characterize this unexpected products
and this is an example of the same
reaction just I think different reagents
the final product expected is 221 but
you see another unexpected pick at 219.
so what is this well if you think about
the mechanism of reaction it's easy to
know it's just a email non-reduced the
non-reduced intermediate towards the
Amine
but
if you don't know you can take both of
them the 221 and 219 and characterize
them so that in the top on B and D you
see both the msms of the amine and the
amine respectively and you see that they
have very similar fragmentation powders
basically shifted by two units and they
correspond to normal radical losses
induced by the Nitro automatic group
basically usually radical n2o radical
and O followed by Co
but then to generate this ritual species
that only in the amine have also the
loss of molecular hydrogen from each one
of these fragments from the radical
science generator so that's how you can
distinguish them both and you can take
any of these ions and do ms3 for example
and continue your further
characterization if you didn't know what
this species were
you can take these two extremesis now
what if you want to acquire spectral
livers because that's very useful if you
want to do
avalonics or you want to do a untargeted
identification of compounds
and so on but you generally you need
these libraries to be able to compare
spectrum and usually those are tedious
to make because it will take forever
but what we did is take 20
and something thousand compound Library
put them on the blades and then screen
them acquire msms Spectra from all of
them very efficiently we're spending
just about five seconds on your sample
and in this way you think high quality
Spectrum as you see on the bottom right
of the screen and you'll think high
density information from all these
molecules which is Consolidated to the
histogram and the 2dm FMS plot which is
this blue square that has on the axis
the product and will receive values and
the precursor democracy values in which
you can start identifying Trends where
diagonal allows lines correspond to
Common neutral losses the fragment that
is lost without charge after
fragmentation of of an ion and then
common product ions which are the
horizontal lines across
and so with all this information of
course you could fit machine learning
algorithms for a structural oxidation
now the second step on this cycle is
this
technology show you what I like about
the synthesis which is kind of the
concept behind it
we've talked about the screening organic
reactions we've talked about having this
accelerated reactions in the droplet but
then
how we're going to do synthesis with the
whole set well what if instead of
sampling those droplets with the mass
spectrometer that is what we've shown in
the past couple slides what if you put
something in between and collect the
drops if these droplets have the
products of accelerator reactions then
at the end of the day that's what you
want
so you can collect those products
and then use that collected material
directly to perform a biosity because
you're collecting nanogram amounts of
material
um but that is enough to test biological
activity in many or most of the cases
so what we've used currently is just
paper put paper in between collect the
products the serve the paper and test
and so this is that links the reaction
screening you're going to collect the
price of successful reactions that you
deem Successful by the msms profile
that you characterize with online msms
etc etc and then you take those
materials collect them and put them on
the BIOS the question is how we're going
to do the value I say well we're going
to do it exactly with the same platform
exactly with the same workflow
but the question says okay why don't we
use conventional kind of biology
strategies right
everyone who's displayed readers why
don't we just take this and throw it on
a plate reader which is already
done under commercial kits and so on
well the thing about play readers and
and most commonly done High super
bioassays is that they involve this
Optical or radiometric readout but most
biological systems in both no colored
fluorescence or naturally radio labeled
suspicious
species that means that you're going to
have to change your systems you're going
to have to modify your substrate you're
going to have to label them you're going
to have to couple secondary actions that
gives you detectable outputs and this
limits the versatility of these assets
you're going to have to start from a
scratch every time you develop a new one
every time you change your enzyme every
time you change the substrate and also
introduce words more work more expenses
even safety concerns to this assays and
furthermore it introduces interferences
so what do we want to do well why don't
we use a label free linearly label free
method as mass spectrometry and we take
the advantages of Desi which now it's
allowing us to sample really really fast
and because of this micro extraction
process that I mentioned at the
beginning it has very high tolerance to
complex mixtures including buffers salts
and detergents and so on which is what
you will typically put in a biogasm
which will be typically detrimental to a
normal kind of ESI Mass spectrometry
analysis
to how to divide assets work basically
in the exact same way the exact same
workflow but the biosis incubate them
coins then transfer 15 analogers with
the pin tool generate high density
arrays with up to 6144 samples per plate
performance vectoral analysis and do
automatic data processing there is
absolutely no sample work have no
purification no separation involved
anywhere and of course it has advantages
of being completely label free you can
use the native systems of your study as
they are you don't have to change
anything of the actual reaction you want
to study being very fast in terms of the
screening super simple you can use the
same workflow to any system you want to
study that also increases the
versatility and what we really like to
emphasize is that it gives you excellent
quantitative performance which is
something that people don't usually
think about ambient ionization
techniques but we obtained relative
standard deviations typically below 10
in most of the determinations we do and
because we have such a high density of
spots available we can do multiple
replicates of a sample to actually get
an average value if that's needed
so how does this typically look well let
me show you here an example of
acetylcholinester is an important enzyme
for the nervous system if you put
different fractions as if you call a
different time points of the
acetylchronster race reaction you will
see that at the beginning everything is
as if you're calling and as you move
down in time going down in this line
down you will see that it turns from 146
that as I said you're calling to 104
which is common
and with this information you can just
plot the ratio of these ions over time
and then monitor the experimental
progression of the reaction which you
can then calibrate and uh in the
estimate initial reaction velocities to
mikhailisment and Analysis find all the
kinetic parameters that you want in this
mechanism plot behind there are many
reactions progress curves with many
replicates each so we have more than 2
000 samples on this plot but it just
takes about 30 minutes to do it with a
high throughput system and the
parameters that you get agreed pretty
well what you find reported on the
literature
um then you can also screen inhibitors
for example and we develop a workflow to
a screen up to create it for Inhibitors
in just 15 minutes of course you can
stream way more just take a little bit
more time you can take any of these
active Inhibitors and then characterize
it further for example through those
response curves as you see on the right
to estimate ic50 curves to estimate ic50
values or to the examples who estimate
Innovation mode and Innovation constants
and so on of course the digital plots
involved that you change both the
substrate and inhibitor concentration
over time they require a lot of samples
this particular plot has more than four
thousand samples behind which is
something not as scalable to do if you
don't have
apology
and um
the one we also demonstrated with the
system is that you can do in
reactivation
so this enzyme gets inhibited by
chemical warfare agents and using
chemical warfare agent stimulants you
can simply inhibit the reaction and then
reactivate it using commercial auxins
and this is something that traditional
methods cannot do because
um a traditional methods Basin using
entire callings of acetylcholine and
fire calling is quite susceptible to be
broken apart by the oxide itself so you
read out comes from who knows the
reaction that is the effect that's been
reactivated or the oxygen that is
breaking through substrate whereas we
because we're using the native substrate
we have absolutely no breakup of
acetylcholine and we can monitor these
reactions for hours at multiple
different concentrations of oxymes which
is limits quite a bit the normal typical
assets
the thing I run out of time so I'll just
let this slide on the PDF but this is
the latest case that we've studied on
this reference here on the bottom of the
corner and it's related to process a
prostate cancer related enzyme so
cholesterol sulfate accumulating plastic
cancer and that's something that was
found with the CMS
and
um then this implies that not only you
accumulate the metabolism but also it
has been found that you accumulate and
overexpress the enzyme that produces it
and if you knock down this enzyme you
can induce that of the cancer cells but
there was no real way to study this
enzyme so some collaborators develop a
fluorescent method with some limitations
including needed and initial incubation
between being limited by the purity of
the reactant including having a lot of
competitive interferences between the
coupled enzyme and the actual enzyme you
want to study and we develop a
completely label-free method using the
high throughput that CMS technology that
gives you comparable results to those
of the fluorescent method as you see
here especially in terms of affinities
finding that the enzyme has way higher
affinity for pregnant women than DHEA
than cholesterol contrary what it was
found before and we've been able to
identify that Inhibitors that were
thought to be good Inhibitors with this
couple fluorescent enzyme assay are
actually not very good inhibitors for
the enzyme that you want but I good
inhibitors for the other one and Sona
using this method we're trying to find
inhibitors for the actual enzyme that
interests us regarding the prostate
cancer
treatment
and with that I just like to finish
reminding you of the three pillars of
the CMS system which in both High
throughput the screening of organic
reactions nanoscale synthesis collecting
these droplets that carry the products
of accelerated reactions and then
testing them online with high Trooper
label free biological analysis that
we've demonstrated in several biological
systems including enzyme but also
receptors which I didn't show in these
slides and thank you so much for
listening to this presentation I'll just
like to thank all the people that have
funded us our research in the lab and
also personally me like Eastman and the
division of analytical chemistry of the
ACs and all our collaborators and the
people that have made this possible
throughout the years including my lab
members thank you so much